Michael B Jordan is actual body goals
dude looks like a Renaissance sculpture
but he didn't use to ever wonder how he
got so jacked meet his trainer
I am celebrity trainer Cory Calle and I
am celebrity training for the stars I
love training when I transformed my body
became an addiction and it turned into
my career you may see me on a lot of
different movie sets but you have seen
my client Michael B Jordan he's been
training Michael B Jordan for years so
Michael B Jordan is one of my best
friends we connected on Fantastic Four
where I was hired to train the cast he's
the only one that allowed me that
trained him I'm the rest of the cast
didn't believe I can do the work or they
were too scared to try me because I was
bigger and we knew Mike he wanted to get
in shape and when we saw each other it
was like you know meet each other and
meet the new family member at the first
sight and since then on you know it's
been like family best friends trained I
mean every day all day is just what we
do actors often have to change their
bodies between the films but Cory says
that Michaels body is a whole other
beast so Mikey body changes all depends
on the script it depends on the film and
we need them to be jacked and looking
mean we're gonna change it up if he
needs to be ripped it all depends on
what are we doing so the Black Panther
was different I went back to my you know
past when it comes to bodybuilding I
wanted to create something that would
actually scare people look like a really
make people be surprised to see him look
make him look intimidating so we did a
lot of weight training there was a lot
of super compound steps it was a very
very very rigorous transformation and it
was different than we did the first time
because it was putting on sides to get
bigger Mike loves working his arms as
you can tell the first time we did three
two he had a peak on top of his bicep so
it looked like he had a bicep in a
little and on top and his least-favorite
work out working his legs not saying he
had chicken legs at all but doing legs
with me I hate it too Corey doesn't just
train clients he also plays a big role
on set so being on set for me is not
just being a trainer it's being the eyes
by the director being the eyes behind my
client as well because I'm able to see
things they can't see of course when it
comes to the body I'm able to see what I
can do to perfect his body look
different so some shots mean these may
need to be more intense invited me to
live
a lot of times like I'm free to direct
the call Corey how does this look
because he's looking at it from a
different angle and I'm looking at it
from a different angles so I'm looking
at a viewer that's looking at to say you
know what it's artistic I like what's
going on right here so I'm a lot
involved I'm on set all day I'm watching
it takes over and over and over again
I'm getting a lot of input the
Challenger every memory I remember about
Michael Mike is like it's almost like
going to my kids graduation and once he
takes his robot you see his body it's
like we have this thing where we look
for each other in there he's in the ring
I'm some wherever we see each other and
we know we did it and that's one of my
most proudest and most memorable moments
and every movie that we've done